wie häufig ist es tatsächlich gerade in
diesen zeiten dass menschen ganz allein
in altenheim sterben ja wir haben die
erfahrungen ja in deutschland schon im
frühjahr gehabt und sie werden sich
erinnern sowohl die bundeskanzlerin als
auch der bundesgesundheitsminister beide
haben uns versprochen das was im
frühjahr geschehen ist die isolation die
einsamkeit auch stärken der allein zu
lassen das wird sich dann nicht mehr
wiederholen
auch dieses versprechen wird nicht
gehalten
es ist ungefähr so dass ein drittel
aller pflegeheime
wir reden also von 4.000 m in
deutschland zurzeit gar nicht besucht
werden können weil er eine entsprechende
infektion ein virus nachgewiesen worden
ist in diesen einen und sie merken davon
sind zehntausende
man kann sogar sagen hunderttausende von
pflegeheimbewohnern und mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeitern betroffen
das heißt was fordern sie jetzt konkret
von der bundesregierung aber auch von
dem bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
verstehen wir haben jetzt die
entscheidung die klar ist die bund
länder konferenz hat ergeben wir müssen
sofort mit den testungen täglich
anfangen vor jedem ein und als
unterstützung auch für vergessen wir das
nicht die ambulanten dienste sofort
heißt wir müssen sicherstellen dass aus
virus gestoppt wird durch schnelltests
sowohl bei den besucherinnen besucher
als auch bei den pflegeheimbewohnern
aber vergessen wenn ich denn die
schleppen das virus oft ein ohne es zu
wissen gerade besonders bei den
pflegekräften und pflege mitarbeitern
und genau darum geht es der auftrag ist
klar aber wir erleben zurzeit ein
fingerhakeln wer bezahlt denn und wie
hoch dürfen die kosten seien
und es sieht so aus dass das
bundesgesundheitsministerium und sagt ja
18 euro für den test inklusive des
materials sei zu teuer
jeder von uns vor spielschluss sie und
alle unsere zuschauer wissen wenn ich
zum arzt gehe zahle ich locker 50 80
euro bei den schnelltest auf den
schnellen teststationen ganz unter 40
euro nicht möglich sein dieses
fingerhakeln um die kosten das muss ein
ende haben
der beschluss ist da der
gesundheitsminister soll sie jetzt nicht
um die machtfrage der cdu kümmern um
politische spielchen wer dies geht in
der partei weiter nein er ist
gesundheitsminister und übernimmt die
verantwortung dafür dass die beschlüsse
jetzt umgesetzt werden und das heißt
sofort unverzüglich mit den
hilfsorganisationen zusammen
die tests zu organisieren 30.000
zusätzliche helfer zu organisieren das
geld bereitzustellen
wir müssen heute helfen denn eins ist
doch klar frau stehen wir warten jetzt
auf eine impfung kommt nicht sofort und
wir wissen auch dass wir zweimal geimpft
werden müssen also ist keine zeit zu
verlieren und es ist jetzt zu handeln
also am besten am sonntag der hand
schönherr frisch für ihre klaren
vorteilen auch diesen klaren appell an
den bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
vielen dank und einen schönen abend ihn
noch passen sie gut auf sich auch
verstehen so auf alles denken sie auch